how do you manifest that external thing
from happening that job offer from
happening that thing you're projecting
that out in the field but what is the
response mechanism that actually calls
that back to you uh well we need three
bottles of wine three hours
uh but let's make it really simple
um
70 of the time people live in survival
live in stress
and there that invisible field of
electromagnetism that's surrounding the
body that resource of energy
is going to be squandered into chemistry
every time you react
the field around your body shrinks a
little bit more and you become more
matter
less energy more particle less wave
and then the hormones of stress cause
you to narrow your focus on the cause so
when you narrow your focus on the cause
you're focusing on the particle in
quantum physics matter and your senses
are take so conditioned into focusing on
matter that you're beginning to
experience separation so the more i live
by the hormones of stress the more i
have separation there's separation
between me and you and my senses are
fooling me into it but the unified field
says there is no separation so then
if you're addicted to those emotions and
you're you're they're heightening your
senses that's what they do in survival
and you become a materialist
and your field around your body's
shrinking then you're going to feel
separate from the quantum field and it's
going to take
a long time for you to create what you
want because you're separate from the
field and you will be madder trying to
change matter so the moment you begin to
activate the center this is our
connection this is our first connection
to the unified field the moment energy
moves into this center and we've
measured this the field around the body
expands and once their energy in the
heart guess where it goes straight up to
the brain the heart acts as an amplifier
and
literally it begins to increase energy
in the brain
so now once that field begins to expand
and you get beyond you take all of your
attention off your body of people in
your life the things you own the place
you need to be in time itself and you
become pure consciousness and you take
all of your attention out of this
three-dimensional reality out of the
known and you start putting your
attention on that field there is a
technique that we teach to do that and
you begin to feel connected from that
field
now
the faster the frequency the higher the
emotion you feel the shorter amount of
time it's going to take for it to appear
in your life because the faster the
frequency the closer you're getting to
oneness and wholeness so then when you
teach people how
to get beyond all of the elements in
this three-dimensional reality and begin
to open their heart their heart in that
frequency is their connection to the
field the moment they open their heart
they become more energy than matter more
wave than particle and now that becomes
the amplifier that begins to generate a
whole new set of thoughts
a whole new consciousness and that heart
center then makes us want to serve
makes us want to take care of one
another to inform one another to help
one another to give to one another to
heal one another that's that's what
creates unity we know this to be the
case we've taken a thousand people in a
room
we've set 50 people in the front of the
room wearing hrv monitors heart rate
monitors and we've told the entire
audience to move into heart coherence
and brain coherence and have the intent
for the greatest good for the people
sitting in the front of the room in a
matter of seconds all their hearts go
into coherence at the exact same time
in the exact same day in the exact same
meditation
they're being influenced by energy and
their autonomic nervous system is being
entrained to a new frequency so imagine
then you begin to change your energy you
begin to affect many people in your life
and those people don't have to be right
there next to you where you're touching
because when you put that intent out
we're all so much more connected than we
i'll ever believe and we are connected
we are we are connected and that now
you're creating from the field so
imagine then if you're connect if you're
feeling connected to all possibilities
then it makes sense then that once
you're connected you don't have to worry
about how it's going to happen and when
it's going to happen it's none of your
business it's like your consciousness is
already communicating with the
consciousness of all of the collective
consciousness around you which we're all
connected to ultimately and the closer
you get to source
the more you can surrender and go deeper
the more connected you are
then how it plays out in
three-dimensional reality leave it up to
the greater mind and just live as if
your future has already happened hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you two
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
attract things quickly into your life
enjoy
rule number two is visualize with jay
shetty visualization the recreation of
images sounds and environments before it
has happened is one of the most powerful
skills in the world a very powerful
meditation and mindfulness practice
visualization has been used for
centuries to help prepare the mind the
body and the consciousness for upcoming
challenges situations and circumstances
some of the world's greatest athletes
use visualization as a way to prepare
for big games the big day musicians for
their new concerts and chores and ceos
for their very important meetings
psychologist alan richardson set out to
prove the power of visualization through
an experiment that i want to share with
you today
that's great
richardson gathered a group of
basketball players and arranged them
into three different groups the intent
of this study was to demonstrate the
effectiveness of visualization in how
the players converted free throws
nothing but net the three groups were as
follows the first group practiced 20
minutes every day the second group
visualized themselves making free throws
but didn't participate in practice the
third group did not practice free throws
or visualization at all you don't have
to do anything the results were
absolutely staggering the group that
only visualized free throws and didn't
practice at all showed marked
improvement and were nearly as accurate
as the ones that practiced for 20
minutes every single day
what it showed is that visualization and
the recreation of that moment in time
allowed people to prepare mentally to
the effect of 20 minutes a day of
practice now the group that didn't
practice or didn't visualize at all
naturally regressed they took a step
backward what this has shown in
countless other examples as well is how
visualization with action with practice
can be the formula that we've all been
looking for often we get forced into
action without visualization and
although that really gets us going and
that practice really does make us
perfect that visualization can start the
process with more confidence more
conviction and more courage rule number
three is put in the work i don't think
people understand that you actually
need to put in the work and be
persistent you just also have to couple
it with a very positive
mindset but you know
will smith talks about
um
the concept of and i've like mentioned
this a lot like laying a brick a day
until you have a wall
you know i think his dad took them you
know the story i'm talking about they
like did the break a day like how are we
going to build a wall and you go out
there and you lay a brick a day so i
really resonate with that whole
um story and concept and i think it's
really true i think a lot of people are
just focused on the whole bigger picture
and like how am i going to be this
famous musician like i haven't even made
a song yet it's like you're not supposed
to be thinking about like
all that to the point where it's
daunting and crippling you're just
supposed to you know what i know i'm
gonna get there i can feel what it's
like but in the meantime i'm gonna lay a
brick a damn or make a song a day or
make it be today or find samples every
day or study every day like as long as
you're doing something towards the
bigger picture a small thing every day
you're good that's real that's real and
that's how it has to be built yeah also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four let go of beliefs
that hold you back with gabby bernstein
everyone has unresolved areas where they
are out of alignment due to their
upbringing their
belief systems from childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted
so some people might be health some
people might be sex some people it might
be money some people it might be their
worth some people might be all of the
above whatever we've all got it we've
all got an area or many where we are
misaligned with
the feeling of love and abundance and
and grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are doing anything wrong
it's that you are your awareness of it
is actually major okay
so
the undoing of the lac mentality is a
journey of clearing
the belief systems from a experiential
time in your life right that happens
once again through books like the
universe has your back so fantastic that
you're doing that transform fear to
faith
excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural pathways
from the experiences that we've had as
children particularly young childhood
experiences but the good news is thanks
to neuroplasticity
our brain actually can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our ptsd can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new behavior so one thing that you can
do simply in this moment is to notice
when you are in that lac mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method i've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes i could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy which everyone i hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but
what you can do for yourself you're here
for self-help you're here for gabby to
tell me how i can serve myself
you can be in the proactive development
of new thought patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel
step two forgive yourself for having the
thought it's very simple up there's my
childhood story there's my parents lack
story again up there it is again
all right i forgive myself it just
showed up again because that forgiveness
will dissolve that guilt and tension and
fear that you're manifesting it all that
crap right
third step
choose the next best feeling thought
choose the thought of you know what i
just forgave myself for that thought so
i'm dissolving it in this moment i
actually am listening to the universe
has your back and it's so supportive
then i can actually go and listen to
super attractor so you can go from
thought to thought to thought to reach
for the next best feeling thought and by
the way isn't that an abundant moment i
just gave you something
so your willingness to face the slack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you
right and especially if you're feeling
afraid that you're manifesting things
because you're having the thoughts then
just forgive the thoughts because or
forgive yourself for having the thought
because the moment that you say oh i
forgive myself for that thought or i
forgive that thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized i am not that
thought it's just a thought that i keep
thinking i am not that belief it's just
a thought that i keep thinking rule
number five is believe what you
visualize with rhonda byrne i want you
to know that there's not really any
difference between you walking around in
this world here this is the law of
attraction no difference to that or you
imagining in your mind there's no
difference it doesn't know any
difference between the two
so if you're if you're visualizing it
law of attraction the law of attraction
this is something that you you already
have
and and so if you're not really
believing it it it just kind of means
you need to do it some more
right and um
and
and try and come up with some scenarios
that are really believable to you like
one of the things i would always do to
manifest and i don't know why it just
worked for me i defaulted to this i
would i would imagine i would imagine
telling somebody
what i manifested that it had already
manifested so i would imagine those
phone calls i would imagine talking to a
friend i would imagine people saying you
know saying to me wow how did you get
that where did you get that
so that was really believable to me but
if because if you really want something
then you're going to want to share it
with family and friends and and so that
really worked incredibly well for me so
maybe that might work for you give that
a try i know number six the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
trust your higher self with big sean
that must have been an uncomfortable
place to live
for one or two years when you feel
you're gonna get your break
it doesn't happen your friends are now
moved on yeah and everyone's and i'm
still in the same bed that i grew up in
yeah you know i i was sleeping in a twin
size bed man i'm 18 19 years old you
feel me yeah and
uh it was so frustrating and it was a
test of my ego bro it was a test of my
ego but i was a visual i would visualize
kanye reaching out i would visualize
i just knew that it was gonna happen i
didn't know how and like i was like i'm
gonna make it happen somehow and it just
it did bro and
it's like something you gotta trust
you know imagine you being on a cliff
and it's like there's no more cliff
there
but you like hey man there's an
invisible bridge
you know if you had a if you had a
guidance next to you like you had your
higher self walking next to you
and you're like bro there's nowhere to
walk and he's like i'm telling you if
you take a step it's an invisible bridge
right in front of you and that takes a
lot of faith to walk on that bridge yeah
you know that you can't even see
but that's what i had to do because
that's that's that's the decision i made
your energy dictates your results think
about it when you have felt
positive motivated energized ready to go
courageous bold you show up differently
right you show up differently than when
you're feeling depressed that it's not
going to work out the negative self-talk
someone like you can't do it you're not
getting any momentum you're not getting
the results like think about your own
mental state when you are
[Music]
trying to accomplish a goal
and the difference between when you have
positive energy versus negative energy
it has nothing to do with your skills
has nothing to do with your potential it
has everything to do with how you're
feeling right now
right it's why i say that lack of belief
is the world's number one problem
you don't believe in yourself enough you
don't have the right energy level and so
you don't go off and create even though
you've got it inside you to do it and
you've got the heart and the mission and
the care and the love and you want to do
it
so it's all about changing your energy
states
i think there's a misconception that
people who are high achievers wake up
and just feel energized and motivated
ready to go right today i did not wake
up and say yes
come on
[Music]
let's go take on the day i'm so excited
right that's not how i woke up today i
woke up it was dark outside it's snowing
as you can you can tell here right it's
snowing look at look at what look at
what nina's driving through
stay safe nina
both of our safety depends on it
she's driving through the snow storm
it's dark outside
and i wake up and and the difference is
i don't i don't put my feet on the
ground to get all jazzed up and start
yelling about what a great day it's
gonna be i wake up but i'm tired and
like why is it so dark outside
why we have the snowstorm
you know i'm thinking about the call i
had yesterday with brendon burchard on
zoom and he's showing me his
tropical
puerto rican beach backdrop and i got
canadian snow happening here right now
the difference is
the people who you admire who have the
success who are the high achievers they
don't wake up
like they're a superhuman and extra
motivated
they're just like you the difference is
they have the habits and the routines
where they demand the energy from
themselves they create the energy for
themselves and so there's there's two
things that i want you to start thinking
about how do you do it right like okay
great evan how do i do it how do i
actually change my energy how do i get
it so that i am feeling powerful bold
motivated confident excited on a daily
basis because it is possible and because
you know how great you feel and you know
the results that you get when you're
feeling that way
so two things that i want you to keep in
mind the first one is
having
something in your morning routine that
demands that from you so for me music is
the fastest way to change my state music
i have a playlist called the believe
playlist
it's hashtag believe all caps on my main
channel you can go find it that's the
music i listen to every day that may not
be the thing that gets you fired up but
it is for me
music is the fastest way to change your
state because there are some songs that
when they come on when you hear them it
just makes you want to move you might
get up and dance you might just be
nodding your head you might be tapping
your foot but there are some songs that
come on that make you want to move it
can't just be the same song every day
because then you're going to get sick of
it and bored of it but you make a
playlist of the different music that
when it comes on
it forces you to shift your state
we often put on the music for how we
currently feel
so when you're sad and low and depressed
or upset you put on music that makes you
feel reinforced and you're sad and low
and depressed and upset states
when you're sad and low you don't put on
music to make you feel better you put on
music to keep you where you are that's
the problem that that then what it keeps
you where you are
right when you put on the music for how
you currently feel it keeps you where
you are where what you want to do is use
music to shift your state so when you're
feeling not so motivated when you're
feeling tired when you're feeling low
you put on music that gets you up and
what's going to happen you're going to
feel a little bit more up so putting
that as a part of your daily routine
daily daily daily daily daily daily
daily daily daily daily daily daily
routine it matters it makes a difference
if you if you started your day with
music that would make you feel
energized pumped up motivated ready to
go if you started your day with that
your day will look different your days
will look different your weeks will then
look different your months will look
different and the things that you
accomplish will look dramatically
different okay so that's a daily basis i
need you to shift your morning routine
to incorporate something like that just
try it try for a week and see how you
feel it'll make a difference i promise
step number two is
reacting to the moment so that's what we
do and step number one is we do on a
daily basis in the morning step number
two is when we have something that
we come across
that
makes us feel
less confident that makes us feel scared
that is a big opportunity that makes us
question ourselves doubt ourselves when
you look at your calendar you look at
your emails you look at the results and
you've seen that you're not where you
want to be
the tendency is to beat ourselves up the
tendency is to play scared the tendency
is to act small the tendency is to
procrastinate and go do something else
right you know i've been there you've
been there maybe you are there right now
you know what i'm talking about
energy
is now the reason why we're staying
where we are so how do we shift our
energy in those moments
one remind yourself that you do
difficult things
you do difficult things
that if it's hard that if it's scary
that it's difficult you're gonna do it
you're gonna do it you're gonna show up
you're gonna do it because you do
difficult things
it cuts the brain out of the equation
because now it's time to show yourself
what you can do
instead of overthinking over
procrastinating
and being overly scared life is a series
of changes those of us who are rigid and
inflexible in our thinking often snap
when the winds of change blow
but those of us who are like willow
trees
bend easily and adapt to the new changes
if we refuse to change then life passes
us by and we get left behind
just as a flexible body is more
comfortable to be in
so is a flexible mind more comfortable
to live in
i am open to the new and changing
every moment presents a wonderful new
opportunity to become more of who i am
i flow with life easily
and effortlessly
i now go beyond other people's fears and
limitations
i am not my mother's fears and
limitations nor am i my father's fears
and limitations i'm not even my own
fears and limitations
these are only false thoughts that have
been hanging around in my mind
i can erase them as easily as i can
clean a dirty window when the window of
my mind is clean i can see clearly
the negative thoughts for what they are
and i can choose to eliminate them
it is my mind that creates my
experiences i am unlimited in my own
ability to create the good in my life
life mirrors my every thought
as i keep my thoughts positive life
brings me only good experiences
there is plenty for everyone including
me
there is so much food on this planet
that we could feed everyone
yes there are people who are starving
but it is not the lack of food it is the
lack of love that allows this to happen
there is so much money and so many
riches in the world far more than we
know
if it were all distributed equally
within a month or so those who have
money now would have more and those who
are poor now would once again be poor
for wealth has to do with consciousness
and deservability
there are billions of people on this
planet yet you will hear people tell you
that they are lonely
if we don't reach out love cannot find
us
so as i affirm my self-worth and my
deservability that which i need comes to
me in the perfect time space
availability
the ocean of life is lavish with its
abundance
all my needs and desires are met before
i even ask
my good comes from everywhere and
everyone and everything
all is well in my world
my life has always worked perfectly only
i did not know it i didn't realize that
every negative event in my world was
life reflecting back to me my belief
system
now that i am aware i can consciously
program my thinking process to have a
life that works on all levels
everything in my life works now and
forevermore
my work is deeply fulfilling
when we learn to love what we do then
life sees to it that we will always have
interesting creative occupations
when you are ready emotionally and
mentally for the next step in life life
will move you to it
give your best to life today
i do what i love and love what i do
i know that i am always working in the
right place with just the right people
and that i learn all of the valuable
lessons my soul needs to
learn life supports me
when you follow the laws of life life
will support you abundantly
life created me to be fulfilled i trust
life and life is always there at every
turn
i am safe
my future is glorious
our futures will always represent our
current thoughts
what you are thinking and saying right
now is creating your future so think
glorious thoughts and you will have a
glorious future
i now live in limitless love light and
joy
all is well in my world
i open new doors to life
as i walk down the corridor of life
there are doors on every side each one
opens to a new experience the more i
clear the negative thought patterns from
my mind the more i find doors that open
to only good experiences
my clarity of thinking brings to me the
best that life has to offer
i rejoice in what i have
and i know fresh new experiences are
always ahead of me i greet the new with
open arms i trust life to be wonderful
i claim my own power and i lovingly
create my own reality
no one can do it for you
only you can make your own declarations
in your mind if you give your power to
others then you have none when you claim
your power it is yours use it wisely
i ask for more understanding so that i
may knowingly and lovingly shape my
world and my experiences
i now create a wonderful new job
bless your current job with love and
release it with love to the next person
who takes your place
knowing that you are moving into a new
level of life
keep your affirmations for the new
position clear and positive and know
that you deserve the best
i am totally open and receptive to a
wonderful new position using my creative
talents and abilities working with and
for people i love in a wonderful
location and earning good money
everything i touch is a success
we always have the option of poverty
thinking or prosperity thinking
when we think thoughts of lack and
limitation then that is what we
experience there is no way you can be
prosperous if your thinking is
impoverished
to be successful you need to constantly
think thoughts of prosperity and
abundance
i now establish a new awareness of
success
i know i can be as successful as i make
my mind up to be
i move into the winning circle
golden opportunities are everywhere for
me prosperity of every kind is drawn to
me
i am open and receptive to new avenues
of income
when we are open and receptive life will
find many ways to bring income to us as
we know and affirm that we deserve all
good the infinite source will open new
channels
we often limit our own good by believing
in fixed income and other closed ideas
opening our consciousness opens the
banks of heaven
i now receive my good from expected and
unexpected sources
i am an unlimited being accepting from
an unlimited source in an unlimited way
i am blessed beyond my fondest dreams
i deserve the best and i accept the best
now
the only thing that keeps us from having
the good in our life is that we don't
believe we deserve it
somewhere in childhood we learned that
we didn't deserve and we believed it
now it is time to release that belief
i am mentally and emotionally equipped
to enjoy a prosperous and loving life
it is my birthright to deserve all good
i claim my good now
[Music]
life is simple and easy
the laws of life are simple far too
simple for many people who want to
struggle and complicate things what you
give out comes back to you what you
believe about yourself and about life
becomes true for you
it is that simple
all i need to know at any given moment
is revealed to me i trust myself and i
trust life and all is well the brain
only learns by only we only see reality
based on pattern recognition i memorized
your face now i know louis and if the
pattern matches i know
but if you're creating a future
and you're not clear on that future and
you want all these things but you
haven't
addressed all those circuits and
behaviors and emotions and chemicals of
the past you won't recognize the pattern
you'll walk right past the relationship
you'll never see it so
so i think that there's the preparation
for the relationship
the overcoming
and overcoming and overcoming and
overcoming and overcoming and becoming
all of a sudden now says i am worthy and
the universe only gives us what we think
we're worthy of receiving so when you're
worthy to receive
it's not going to be on match.com when
you're looking at body parts and
whatever else this is going to be like
energy
wow like that came out of nowhere
because when you're in survival
and you're in separation and you're in
lack and you're forcing and controlling
and trying to predict outcomes your
matter trying to change matter and of
course it's going to take time for this
to happen because you're creating a
three-dimensional reality and everything
in three-dimensional reality takes time
but when you're creating from the heart
with a coherent brain and a coherent
heart and you've got that 5g wi-fi
signal
it's it's not like you go anywhere now
there the experiences are coming to
you're drawing the event to you so
so we spend a lot of time
[Music]
bonding with our future emotionally i
have colleagues of mine who look at our
our data on oxytocin and they're like uh
listen oxytocin levels go up during uh
you know when i'm in a relationship the
honeymoon stage of relationship and
monogamy is created because of those
chemicals or
a female mammal is bonding with our
offspring exactly right i want our
people our students to bond
and fall in love with their future just
like they do with somebody else and when
you're bonded to your future
no person no circumstance no thing is
going to remove you from it so then if
you fall from grace during the day
then the next question is what person
what circumstance caused me to
disconnect
from my love in the future
and let me rehearse in my mind if i have
that same circumstance how i'm going to
overcome it open your eyes and be in the
initiation of life and stay in that
place and just know that your future is
going to happen so
so
being able to activate the heart and
breathe in there and get the body out of
survival and start working with it like
it feels safe enough to create once
energy makes it here you're going to get
some really good ideas you're going to
see things you never thought of seeing
you're going to feel things you never
thought you'd feel and the
the images that you're creating what are
they doing the thoughts that you're
creating they're making more of those
chemicals and now you're feeling more of
the the feeling of your future before it
happens you're giving your body a
sampling
a taste of the future before it's
happened keep doing that enough times
and that feeling is going to become very
familiar to you there was a a researcher
out of yale university that
in the 1940s that was studying
electromagnetic fields around living
organisms
and in the 1940s and at yale university
nobody was doing this and he was a
vitalist he wanted to understand the
unseen fields around living organisms
so
he started studying eggs
all kinds of eggs chicken eggs swallow
eggs reptile eggs snake eggs salamander
eggs all kinds of eggs
and he was using a magnetometer and what
he found was what a hundred percent of
the time
no matter what a he measured the
positive charge was always at the head
and the negative charge was always at
the tail well if you have positive
charge on one end the negative charge on
the other end you got a external
electromagnetic field called a magnetic
field that's a magnet right
what happens with human beings
is every thought has a frequency every
thought produces a chemical
so if you keep obsessing
about your lack your lack of finances
your lack of time your lack of energy
lack likewise and those thoughts i don't
have this
what what are the chemicals you're
feeding your body you're taking thought
it's producing a frequency and that
frequency in the form of chemistry is
storing that thought emotionally right
in your second center you feel guilty
you feel unhappy the moment you feel
unhappy then you generate more thoughts
equal to that feeling which makes more
chemicals and you keep taking energy
from the brain and storing it in the
body
if you react to people in your life and
you feel anger frustration whether it's
traffic the news whatever it is
parents whatever you're drawing from
this field
this electromagnetic field you're
tapping that resource and you're making
chemistry out of it and the field
shrinks so now
by doing that and living in survival
the body no longer is a magnet so now
you have very little energy in the brain
in fact five percent of the energy is in
the brain
then 95 is stored in the body now the
body's been conditioned emotionally so a
lot of energy in the body very little in
the brain many people come to me and say
i want to be a millionaire i i and
there's a great song about i'm going to
be a millionaire and they read things
like the secret which says if you want
to be a millionaire just just wish it
and it will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school
i was going to be a nanny that's how
much i thought i could earn in my
lifetime that's what i thought i was
meant to be
but then i worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of it so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must decide
you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out and make
a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help
the more reasons you will have to become
and stay a millionaire and here's the
third thing and this is so important
many people think well i'm just gonna
float around and manifest millions i'm
just gonna sit at home with my sofa and
manifest millions if you want a job you
go out and look for a job if you want a
new home you go out and visit new homes
you want a partner you better go out and
put yourself in front of people and if
you want to make and keep millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hair dryer
took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way it's not about
shall i invent something i don't have an
inventive mind i'm not creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a
multi-multi-million dollar company they
didn't invent a new product well they
sort of did they took an existing
product they made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and chan
on shanti and money will fall from the
heavens we all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now
you must be able to think of
how you're going to what could you
possibly do to make money remember that
woman who changed the face of a floor
mop they made a movie about her and she
became a millionaire and she was a
housewife but one day she was mopping
her floor you know this is not really a
good mop and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i just
manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there
and that's not true i work with
millionaires and billionaires and they
do work hard they work long
and they work hard on their way to
success they work a lot when they get
success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day meeting deadlines i travel all over
the world through time zones giving
talks and sometimes that's tiring i plan
out my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe you can be
a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary
self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and you said
something i always remembered do not die
with your music still inside and i
thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get our
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something and some of the smartest
people create things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson read felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template
and i'm going to follow that template
and if you have the belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire life is a series of changes
those of us who are rigid and inflexible
in our thinking often snap when the
winds of change blow but those of us who
are like willow trees
bend easily and adapt to the new changes
if we refuse to change then life passes
us by and we get left behind
just as a flexible body is more
comfortable to be in
so is a flexible mind more comfortable
to live in
i am open to the new and changing
every moment presents a wonderful new
opportunity
to become more of who i am
i flow with life easily and effortlessly
[Music]
i now go beyond other people's fears and
limitations
i am not my mother's fears and
limitations nor am i my father's fears
and limitations i'm not even my own
fears and limitations these are only
false thoughts that have been hanging
around in my mind i can erase them as
easily as i can clean a dirty window
when the window of my mind is clean i
can see clearly the negative thoughts
for what they are and i can choose to
eliminate them
it is my mind that creates my
experiences
i am unlimited in my own ability to
create the good in my life life mirrors
my every thought
as i keep my thoughts positive life
brings me only good experiences
there is plenty for everyone including
me
there is so much food on this planet
that we could feed everyone
yes there are people who are starving
but it is not the lack of food it is the
lack of love that allows this to happen
there is so much money and so many
riches in the world far more than we
know
if it were all distributed equally
within a month or so those who have
money now would have more and those who
are poor now would once again be poor
for wealth has to do with consciousness
and deservability
there are billions of people on this
planet yet you will hear people tell you
that they are lonely
if we don't reach out love cannot find
us
so as i affirm my self-worth and my
deservability that which i need comes to
me in the perfect time space
availability
the ocean of life is lavish with its
abundance
all my needs and desires are met before
i even ask
my good comes from everywhere and
everyone and everything
all is well in my world
my life has always worked perfectly only
i did not know it i didn't realize that
every negative event in my world was
life reflecting back to me my belief
system
now that i am aware i can consciously
program my thinking process to have a
life that works on all levels
everything in my life works now and
forevermore
my work is deeply fulfilling
when we learn to love what we do then
life sees to it that we will always have
interesting creative occupations
when you are ready emotionally and
mentally for the next step in life life
will move you to it
give your best to life today
i do what i love and love what i do
i know that i am always working in the
right place with just the right people
and that i learn all of the valuable
lessons my soul needs to learn
life supports me
when you follow the laws of life life
will support you abundantly
life created me to be fulfilled i trust
life and life is always there at every
turn i am safe
my future is glorious
our futures will always represent our
current thoughts
what you are thinking and saying right
now is creating your future so think
glorious thoughts and you will have a
glorious future
i now live in limitless love light and
joy
all is well in my world
i open new doors to life
as i walk down the corridor of life
there are doors on every side each one
opens to a new experience
the more i clear the negative thought
patterns from my mind the more i find
doors that open to only good experiences
my clarity of thinking brings to me the
best that life has to offer
i rejoice in what i have
and i know fresh new experiences are
always ahead of me i greet the new with
open arms i trust life to be wonderful
i claim my own power and i lovingly
create my own reality
no one can do it for you
only you can make your own declarations
in your mind
if you give your power to others then
you have none when you claim your power
it is yours use it wisely
i ask for more understanding so that i
may knowingly and lovingly shape my
world and my experiences
i now create a wonderful new job
bless your current job with love and
release it with love to the next person
who takes your place
knowing that you are moving into a new
level of life
keep your affirmations for the new
position clear and positive and know
that you deserve the best
i am totally open and receptive to a
wonderful new position using my creative
talents and abilities working with and
for people i love in a wonderful
location and earning good money
everything i touch is a success
we always have the option of poverty
thinking or prosperity thinking
when we think thoughts of lack and
limitation then that is what we
experience
there is no way you can be prosperous if
your thinking is impoverished
to be successful you need to constantly
think thoughts of prosperity and
abundance
i now establish a new awareness of
success
i know i can be as successful as i make
my mind up to be
i move into the winning circle
golden opportunities are everywhere for
me prosperity of every kind is drawn to
me
i am open and receptive to new avenues
of income
when we are open and receptive life will
find many ways to bring income to us as
we know and affirm that we deserve all
good the infinite source will open new
channels
we often limit our own good by believing
in fixed income and other closed ideas
opening our consciousness opens the
banks of heaven
i now receive my good from expected and
unexpected sources i am an unlimited
being accepting from an unlimited
source in an unlimited way i am blessed
beyond my fondest dreams
i deserve the best and i accept the best
now
the only thing that keeps us from having
the good in our life is that we don't
believe we deserve it
somewhere in childhood we learned that
we didn't deserve and we believed it
now it is time to release that belief
i am mentally and emotionally equipped
to enjoy a prosperous and loving life it
is my birthright to deserve all good i
claim my good now
life is simple and easy
the laws of life are simple far too
simple for many people who want to
struggle and complicate things what you
give out comes back to you what you
believe about yourself and about life
becomes true for you
it is that simple
all i need to know at any given moment
is revealed to me i trust myself and i
trust life and all is well if you can't
feel the emotion of your future
your manifestation of love before it's
made manifest like people say well well
my relationship hat when i find mr right
then i'm going to feel love waiting for
the outer environment to change
to take away this feeling of anger
resentment emptiness but they forgot
that they create reality in other words
when it finally appears that i'm going
to feel love that's that's cause and
effect we're waiting for something to
happen if you're feeling the lack and
the emptiness then you're keeping your
relationship at arm's length because you
don't have the magnetic field
to draw to you
so the emotions that come from these
energy centers the lower energy centers
in our body do have
frequencies there's chemistry involved
but they have a different agenda
so now we ask the person
can you teach
your body emotionally
what the future will feel like before
it's made manifest that means you can't
wait for your relationship to feel love
you have to reverse that battleship and
understand feeling love now is going to
be the magnet and if you can hold the
vision of your future a clear intention
with a coherent brain
organize signals into the field
and you could actually crack this thing
open
and
practice
getting so present in the moment
that you're not anticipating the next
moment or trying to predict the future
and you're no longer romancing the
emotions of your past you can find that
sweet spot of the generous present
moment
the familiar past is the known
emotionally the predictable future is
the habituation of autopilot being
unconscious and programs those are both
knowns there's only one place where the
unknown exists that's the present moment
so if you could work with your body
to the point that it trusts you enough
to feel so safe
that you have conquered it in a certain
way that it could actually relax into
the present moment and it's not worried
about what's going to happen next or
what's going on around around you or
that you need to eat you need to pee you
need to move you got beyond all your
drives and you're you're ready to create
that moment where you're present
if you could begin to
work with your heart
and start to breathe and start to
practice feeling love in the beginning
it would feel foolish or gratitude why
would i feel love if it hasn't happened
well that's because you've been
hypnotized into waiting for your world
to change to feel feel the emotion from
the experience
but according to the quantum model
your emotion ahead of the experience
when you combine that clear intention
with the elevated emotion
and you feel love your body's so
objective
that it's actually believing it's living
in that future in the present moment and
your body now is beginning to change
you are beginning to change your biology
to reflect
what you're about to experience in your
future
so the stronger the
love you feel the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you're going to
pay attention to that picture in your
mind stimulus response
memory emotion
thought and feeling but now you're
remembering your future
instead of remembering your past if
you're truly in the present moment and
you know exactly what you want
and you
begin to teach your body emotion start
practicing opening that heart it's
amazing what happens
the moment that heart begins to open
we've measured this so many times lewis
on a scan on a real-time brain scan
when the heart moves into this kind of
rhythm when you're feeling
frustration
when you're feeling impatient when
you're feeling resentment you are
stepping on the gas pedal and you're
stepping on the brake at the same time
and the heart is pumping against the
closed system and it causes an erratic
beat it becomes incoherent and energy
literally leaves the heart now you no
longer believe in your future you can't
put your heart into your future you
can't trust the outcome because there's
no energy there it's it's being used and
consumed somewhere else so energy is
leaving the brain as well
but once energy starts to move into the
heart we've seen this so many times and
it starts to beat in this rhythm like
banging a drum or dropping a pebble in
water pebble after pebble the heart
begins to create a wave of energy right
to the brain like like taking a big
sheet
and going like that and then all of a
sudden you see this wave and the brain
gets this rush of energy and that change
in brain wave patterns that change that
wave is carrying information
and the person starts to get a very
clear idea they see their future very
clearly now now that energy is causing
them to move into very coherent alpha
brainwave patterns which is the state of
creation this is when you no longer hear
the voice in your head that's talking to
you that you listen to and believe is
the truth i'm not good enough yeah
whatever that is
that's called the default mode it
suppresses the default mode network and
the next thing you know
you start seeing in pictures and images
you start dreaming
and that's the imagination that's the
creative state so now you start
naturally imagining the heart is the
creative center we've got to put our
heart into our future it better be open
and activated
so now when you start falling in love
with your future
oxytocin is released in the brain and in
the heart oxytocin signals nitric oxide
nitric oxide signals another chemical
called endothelial derived relaxing
factor and just like when your sexual
organs get filled with blood because
you're aroused the same thing happens
here as it would happen somewhere else
and literally the arteries in the heart
and lungs engorge and now your heart
feels full and it's thumping in order
and you're
in the present moment now once that
happens and it's beating in rhythm the
heart produces an external magnetic
field up to three meters wide now
you're in survival you're drawing from
the field and turning into chemistry
when you get energy in the heart it's
causing a change in the brain
and all of a sudden it's resetting the
baseline for trauma
and now here you have a magnetic field
now the heart
is your magnet it is it is the center of
creation and now that that energy is
frequency hmm and frequency carries
information and you can lay the thought
of your new relationship
on that energy
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to manifest like joe dispenza check
out the top 10 video i did on him right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there
you start shifting where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so if you're shifting your attention all
over the board your energy is scattered
yeah so then when you start
disconnecting from everybody your boss